for more information on tutoring or how
to support move university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
so the first three quantum numbers that
we talked about or n L and M sub L and
of course describing the energy L
describing the shape and the M sub L
describe the orientation of what though
those are all properties that describe
an orbital an atomic orbital where we
say that electrons can be located okay
the fourth quantum number is electron
spin so it's not property of or an
orbital it describes an actual electron
it's denoted as M sub s that's what
electron spin is denoted denoted as and
basically the idea here is that these
electrons have create little tiny
magnetic fields and so we kind of
represent that port like this and they
can spin in opposite directions like
this okay
forming magnetic fields so there's only
two possible values of this magnetic
spin you have positive 1/2 which is
represented as an arrow pointing up and
negative 1/2 which is represented by an
arrow pointing down right kind of
showing kind of like what this is
representing here right that an electron
spinning in a certain direction has a
certain spin electron spitting in the
opposite direction as the opposite spin
okay so these guys have opposite or
opposing spins so this fourth quantum
number since it's dealing with the
electron not with the orbital it's not
part of the quantum number hierarchy
like the first three numbers okay so now
an orbital we mention this a little bit
before is can be represented by a line
or a box or a circle that can be filled
by electrons filled with electrons so
the maximum occupancy for an orbital is
two electrons and they if they're if
is one orbital here and it it can have
two electrons in it represented by these
arrows so one would be spinning upwards
and one is spinning downwards so okay
whatever
cool what does this mean well now that
we've talked about all four of the
quantum numbers we can assign let's sort
of often call the home address or a set
of quantum numbers for an electron so we
could basically assign and kind of say
where an electron is in terms of these
quantum numbers okay so if we're
thinking about electron in the 1s
orbital so this is the 1s orbital here
you have two electrons in it if we have
if we have one electron with the quantum
numbers N equals 1 l equals 0 so that's
where the 1s comes from M sub L has to
equal 0 M sub s can be plot plus 1/2
which will be represented by this up
arrow so this this is the home address
or the set of quantum numbers that
describes that particular electron the
pink one okay we could have another one
in blue this home address which has all
the numbers the same except M sub s is
negative 1/2 that describes that's the
home address for this electron okay
which brings me to the Pauli exclusion
principle which basically says that no
two electrons can have the same set of
quantum numbers because if there
the same orbital they must have opposite
spins you can't have an orbital that has
two electrons and one goes up and the
other goes up that's not possible
you also can't have them both going down
they're going to be in the orbital they
have to have one going up and one going
down okay so that's Pauli exclusion
principle
so basically no two electrons can have
the same address they both can't live in
the same hole kind of if you think about
it like that so that's the Pauli
exclusion principle and how it relates
to the fourth quantum number electron
spin hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying